in tokyo this morning thousands of
people lined the streets to say farewell
to japan's longest-serving prime
minister that's shinzo abe the retired
leader was assassinated on friday while
making a campaign speech for another
candidate the killing with a homemade
gun shocked japan because firearms are
highly controlled in gun violence there
is really very rare elizabeth palmer
reports from tokyo on abe's funeral
the hearse carrying shinzo abe's remains
took him one last time past the
parliament he'd served as a lawmaker
and then his old headquarters the prime
minister's residence where colleagues
including japan's current prime minister
fumio kashida waited to say a last
goodbye
earlier japan's political elite family
members and close friends had gathered
for a buddhist service
the funeral held at tokyo's zozoji
temple was a private affair but that did
not stop thousands of people from coming
down to get as close as they could to
pay their respects
patiently they waited to pray and paid
tribute to their country's longest
serving prime minister
keiko had come with her daughter ryoka
he did a lot of things for a japanese
people did you want your daughter to be
with you because this is an historic
moment
yes
a proud nationalist and conservative
with a playful side shinzo abe was
confident on the world stage and a
political giant at home
japan is still reeling from his loss
as for the man who killed him he's told
police he did have a grudge against abe
for supposed connections to the
unification church better known as the
mooneys who he blames for bankrupting
his family tony
liz palmer for us in tokyo liz thank you
very much